he is the Pro Football Hall of Famer II
from the Green Bay Packers way back in
the day obviously Vikings as well but
for this subject at hand he's uh he's
perfect and he's our friend and he's
Brett Favre how are you Brett I'm good
rich about you I'm hanging in this have
a 50th birthday party well it's coming
up Brett it is coming up Big Five oh you
know some people are not looking forward
to you know that birthday are you mm-hmm
you know what Brett you I it's it's
something that I've been told is just a
number it's just a number you're not too
far away from a to yourself are you know
just a couple months apart mine comes
knock I'm like you you know first of all
it is what it is you can't do anything
about it that's true but you know I do I
feel 50 or almost 50 no I don't know if
that's good or bad
I assume good that you know you look
good it looks like you keep selling in
good shape right nowadays people tend to
take better care of themselves anyway
well you're also you're more advanced
anyway than me Brett I mean you're in
the hall you're in a Hall of Fame you
know I just talked about it and and you
your grandfather
Brett I mean your way down the road in
terms of things that human beings have
done then I'm old man in some respects
I'm very old and others I you know maybe
not so much but hey just weathered year
in the Hall of Fame or not doesn't
doesn't make me any younger than you I
know I know so I just wanted to pick up
the phone and I you know obviously mooch
I don't know if you saw what he had to
say on the NFL Network over the weekend
about Bart Starr it was tremendous it
was typical Mariucci just just pouring
his heart out that he wears in his
sleeve for a guy who he would watch
through a chain-link fence when he would
drive from the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan to go watch Bart Starr practice
with the Lombardi Packers and I'm I'm
wondering what your recollections are of
Bart Starr I just throw it open to you
right yeah so I don't know what else you
can say that hasn't been said by so many
people and and obviously all those
things are you know tremendous
personality character integrity nice
thoughtful is it and all those are true
you know he was a little before my time
as FAR's
watched him play and remembering him
like I do
Roger Stahl back who was my child
childhood idol and who I emulated but
you know I've said this so many times
you know when I was traded to green baby
I wasn't real sure where Green Bay was
but I was for certain I knew who Bart
Starr was I knew what he stood for I
knew that he quarterback two Packers in
what would be you know the as they can
say now the glory years oh and and just
was a an icon I knew that I knew Paul
Hornung you know I knew a new Willie
wood and Willie Davis I knew all those
guys who they were and what they had
done and so when I got a chance to to
meet Barton I don't think it was I in
all honesty I don't know the exact time
I can't remember if that was you know
prior to the start of the first season
somewhere I I don't remember but I do
remember Bart would always draw out of
his way to come say hello and I just
thought to myself I mean this is crazy
why would he want to talk to me and you
know just a very humble guy and you know
one thing that he did and you may have
may or may not have seen this but he
always would send me a personal letter
after I accomplished you know something
not necessarily
something of many magnitude it may have
been my first win it may have been you
know a three-game stretch or have been
you know I didn't play as as well and we
at us loss send me a nice let you know
there'll be better days
you know thinking of you you know proud
of you know all those things and he
didn't have to do that and and I'm sure
that there's other people out there who
could say Barnes did this for him or he
went out of his way in and helped us out
you know in some sort of way that's just
the type of guy was you know I would
guess if there's any and I don't
consider this a negative in any way if
there's one thing you could say that
maybe he didn't accomplish was what he
had set out to would have been as a head
coach right and probably the reason for
that was he's probably too nice you know
and I mean that with all due respect
just just a wonderful wonderful person
you know and that's the thing I was out
of what you just said Brett that I
wanted to pull out about just a stellar
human being that that Bart Starr was and
how he he would come up to you when you
were just fresh being traded to the team
from Atlanta and and then about how he
would stay along with you I mean as it
was now obvious in Green Bay that you
were in fact the person that this
organization had been writing for since
Bart and I wonder how how he handled
that with you with handwritten notes
literally you would just walk to the
mailbox and there be a handwritten note
from or in your locker from Bart Starr
Brett yes either way if not those and
may he always made a point when he was
in Green Bay I'm sure there were times
where he you know dropped in maybe you
know to go to Boys Ranch or
something where he was not coming over
to the facility where I didn't know he
was in town but I got to impress at
every every time he was in town he come
over his hell up you know and he was
unassuming he didn't want it's any
fanfare or anything like that you know
he just you know again a very humble guy
and you know not you know what about me
you know what you know and along those
same lines that one of the things I'm
most proud of is being able to come back
to Green Bay as I did and to be welcomed
by the fans the way I was but to be able
to do it with our star on that Thursday
night the cold and raining game and and
really it was supposed to be and a night
honoring me but I really felt like it
was a night to to honor bark one last
time and and you know that's one of the
great memories that I have of Dino
Lambeau Field bleep it hot yeah I mean I
was gonna bring that up with you Brett
and might as well just do that right now
Brett Favre here on the Rich Eisen show
a couple days after the passing of the
great Bart Starr it was moving for me
okay me for me because I've known you
for as long as I've known you and it was
I knew it was a big night for you to be
back in Lambeau Field after what
happened
coming back from Minnesota and it was a
big night for you and your family and
the Packer family just all come together
and the question was could Bart Starr
make it there could it would what his
health hold up enough to make it there
and then I turn on the TV and I see him
there with you and obviously Aaron
Rodgers as well and I started tearing up
I'm wondering what it was like for for
you Brett oh I can't even describe how
it felt and how as I think back now you
know I I just I get chill bumps and what
people don't know about that was we
actually were going to do it the preview
year around the same time a night game
late in the year and his health was not
up to par in they wanted to plan enough
in advance I was not going to do it at
that time
unless Bart could do it I really wanted
to do it with him and and so we had
planned on doing it the previous year
and his health just was was very erratic
and you you know I thought maybe this
will never happen so that season passed
and I want to say that somewhere between
the end of that season and the time that
he actually was able to make it you know
he did the stem cell I think in Mexico
you know it's something along those
lines and his health improved you know
not long term but long enough to be able
to come up and and and make an
appearance and we were able to you know
you you know it is before game it's very
hectic and of course smart and I are not
playing anymore Aaron goes out of his
way and we take this picture and I knew
when we sat down to take that picture
that this would be the last time we'd
ever do it and and how special a moment
that would that was I really that really
had sunk in at that point that this will
never happen again and you know this is
an iconic picture if there ever was one
well I mean he had to have known it -
what was he like that night right um you
know I saw two sides of Bart that night
I saw the old Bart where he was engaging
and things seemed to be well aware of
what was going on and then that there
were times when we were back you know
prior to the game trying to get the
picture taken where he was a little bit
in and out and at times I
I felt like he really wasn't sure what
was going on her who even who we were
but you know and so it was kind of mixed
emotions you know was sad to see him
like that but also it was you know it
was a proud moment for me to see him
there in person and to be able to to one
last time I knew that we were going to
be Allen's you know a Lambeau Field and
and the crowd was going to just cheer as
you would imagine they would for Bart
one last time and I think he really and
I'm sure you remember seeing his face
you know up close I mean you could you
could see that he was like a kid in a
candy store and that was that was great
to see well Brett I just wanted to have
you on earth talk about these memories
and I you know I I know it's emotional
for you and your family to see the
passing of Bart Starr and it's not just
obviously him we saw Jerry Kramer going
last year I mean this is what we're
seeing an end of an era in a way closing
oh a wonderful a wonderful wonderful era
and tremendous players but more
importantly you know I'm sure Bart would
say the same thing you know he doesn't
want to be remembered as a great pack
for or a great quarterback there's way
more to it than that
and and I think we all know him are
thankfully knowing should should say oh
he was much much bigger much better than
than just a football player you know he
was just a tremendous person and and
that's that's what's most important
right have a great day man thanks for
joining
really appreciate you chiming in right
here on a very moving weekend and
remembering and commemorating an
all-time great in Bart Starr brother hey
you're welcome rich and I have a happy
50th birthday party I don't think I can
make okay break oh that's what that's
okay you'll like mine right oh yeah just
send me that send me that that evite
I'll look forward to the you know the
Eva
popping up from the envelope and I'll be
all over that you let me know you got it
always right back at your breath that's
Brett Favre hall-of-famer right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app